if the world
had to survive an entire day with no
energy
i think that there would be quite a lot
of chaos
in many places i think some of the
cities especially
would have a very hard time some people
would enjoy the day quite a lot i think
they'd enjoy
not having their cell phones and
computers and
it would probably be a very relaxing day
i know i enjoy going backpacking in the
mountains and
using no energy other than my camp stove
but there are a lot of places where
there would be real problems our
our hospitals would be in a
very difficult situation and a lot of
people
wouldn't be able to get food or water
so we're certainly very dependent on
energy right now and it would be a
crazy day if the whole world didn't have
energy
i guess we could all sit in our living
rooms and read books
assuming the batteries on our ipads and
kindles were still
working and if not i guess we could read
old-fashioned books by candlelight
somehow we'd survive of course anyone
involved in
anything critical going on that day if
you needed
an operation i wouldn't want that being
done under under candlelight
so you know could the world survive
without energy for a day
i think most people could most people do
on a global basis
maybe uh it would be a nice breather for
a lot of people who lead
hectic lifestyles well we've sort of
seen that occasionally right there being
some pretty big
blackouts in which uh you know the power
was down for substantial periods of time
in fact when i was a professor at
stanford
the power went down here for four days
due to some sort of due to a storm that
blew through and put down a lot of power
lines and so
i remember it as being a very very
frustrating period of time because i
couldn't do my email
so how do we survive is absolutely no
energy use
i think the best way is go to sleep
don't consume energy
you